How real is the chatter about Iraq?
Very.
Are you looking to an Iraqi connection?
No one has actually come out and said anything publicly.
Maybe it's just backroom speculation.
Can we hit it harder than this?
I know that a man named Ahmed Chalabi wants to replace Saddam Hussein,...
...that the Neocons are pushing for the invasion...
...and you are quickly becoming my favorite writer.
Wow!
Proof is coming from every major media outlet in the country except yours.
We're all right, aren't we?
I'm speaking to you because I'm an American citizen...
...and I don't like what these people are doing.
You've got to see this.
What do we do?
When the government says something, you only have one question to ask.
Is it true?
Search is underway to find those responsible.
We write for people whose kids get sent to war.
Our readers need to know.
The President is gonna invade Iraq.
We're gonna run it whether he comments or not.
The President is lying.
He's lying!
It was a setup.
There's always something you don't see coming.
They don't care about the truth.
They want a war.
They're gonna get one.